here's what I do specifically to help
myself stay focus we develop addictions
because we escape from pain one of the
things that human beings underestimate
dramatically is their capacity to get
great at something if they're totally
immersed in it why not be happy build a
life not just a business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
millionaires defeat distractions enjoy
so let's kick it off with rule number
one start your day off right with Mel
Robbins here's what I do specifically to
help myself
stay focused first things first when I
wake up in the morning I do not sleep
next to my phone the reason why I don't
sleep next to my phone is because if you
sleep next to it or use it as your alarm
your tendency is to look at it while
you're in bed that means that you're
checking email before you've even
thought about what your priorities are
do not do that that's tip number one tip
number two I have a pad of post-it notes
yes post-it notes next to my sink in my
bathroom
well because after I brush my teeth
haven't looked at my phone yet I take a
post-it note out and I write the three
things I need to focus on today and then
you know what I do with it I stick it on
the back of my phone now why would I do
that because I have my phone with me all
the time and so if it's on the back of
my phone I'm gonna get a visual cue to
remind me I keep it top of mine so I
stay focused on it third thing that I do
it's a little trick I call 30 before
7:30 what that means I spend 30 minutes
before 7:30 a.m. just focused on getting
my day organized and getting a few of
the things that are my top priorities
either finished or further down the
field so that's 30 minutes before 7:30
a.m. that's time for me
if you utilize those three things don't
sleep with your phone
right after you brush your teeth right
out your three priorities and stick it
on the back of your phone just like this
and spend 30 minutes before 7:30 for
yourself I promise you you'll be shocked
and how much more focused you are and
you feel
rule number two block your time with
Brendon Burchard if you'd not doing
block time here's what your day might
look like you have all these different
slots of time right and you're just
gonna plug in as you go through the day
you're gonna plug in
oh I'll work some there and I'll work
some there and then I'll try to cram
stuff up right at the end of the day
I'll try to cram that sucker in any
Crammers Crammers Crammers grammars okay
just checking
no judgment no judgement you're just not
going as fast as you could that's all
Crammers there I love Crammers yeah just
like because they're easy to get to move
faster because you do have that
diligence of when there's a deadline and
it's on you can go which really serves
you but we had to get from a Krammer to
a preparer to a high performer and the
way that we do that is to look at this
and go listen if you keep leaving all
these time slots to randomness what
happens is they start to get filled with
the Big D
distraction some reason it seems like
this hit home for some people I don't
know why how do you recognize what I'm
talking about here so now you add up
take this out you might not be thinking
too serious about it but let's say
that's like a day 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
work hours you didn't know I drew that
on purpose
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness bit by
bit
hour by hour day by day week by week
month by month quarter by quarter year
by year and decade by decade and it's
the little things like this where you're
like oh my gosh I didn't get anything
done because you've got all these random
approaches to your day and so for those
who are like but Brendan I'm a free
spirit I'm like oh god I love free
spirits me too let's go on a yoga
retreat I don't have any time hold free
spirit no time for yoga retreat
oh you know why freeze pretty I don't
have a real good retreat cuz they got no
discipline if they had some discipline
free spirit would have time for some
yoga retreat so if you want more free
time you need more discipline time it's
so simple my friend Evan Carmichael book
listen humans are built to serve some
people are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them but neither case humans
are building surf so if you're not happy
right now it's because you're not
serving enough
you got to pick up this book is so
inspiring to remind you that we're all
here to contribute to make a difference
to make an impact and this is your field
guide for that skill number three create
a bat cave moment with Dan Locke how can
you be productive in any given time
during the day if you're interrupted all
the time I think even entrepreneurs CEOs
they have this like open door policy
where hey you know what my door is open
come talk to me anytime I think it was
one of the dumbest ideas because it
means you get interrupted many many many
times every single day and every time
you get interrupted it takes you so the
mental bandwidth to stay and get back on
track so when I am working pluck the
phone I create an environment that
people cannot reach to me if I want to
check messages I want to check email or
to get back to my team that's fine but
if I am what I call the bat-cave moment
I unplug all communication my cell phone
my none zero it's all my thinking time
my planning time my strategy time that's
it so when they cannot find you they
cannot interrupt you when they cannot
find you they cannot distract you so
communicate with your team and people
around you and say hey I'm working on my
business I'm building something here I'm
working with some very very important
tasks I need to get those done please
give me the space during that time don't
bother me zooming in the office when I'm
working some lands from home when I
close the door then Jenny knows right
that she doesn't come in and interrupt
me right my wife knows that no that's
Dan's working time he needs to stay
focused so what does have an environment
that you cannot be distracted
number four get laser focused with EDM
I'd let one of the things that human
beings underestimate dramatically is
their capacity to get great at something
if they're totally immersed in it
totally laser focused on something but
as I've coached the very high-end
athletes in my life the top
businesspeople and entertainers I can
tell you that most people underestimate
what total obsessive laser focused
really is and what it looks like because
you are way more powerful than you know
you are if you went crazy psycho
obsessed laser focused on anything even
something you're totally ill-prepared
for humans have an unreal capacity to
get great at things even if they don't
of a natural talent for it if they're
immersed in it and to learn something
and acquire a ton of knowledge in a
short period of time as well society is
conspiring all the time in our culture
to completely distract you so you never
win to just divert your focus and
attention look over here look at this
shiny thing look at this TV show look at
this sports team worried about what's
going on here in this war and they get
these different things on television and
our phones and in our lives they just
get us distracted so we never get
obsessed we never get laser focused for
an extended period of time I think
there's a different level for you I mean
I think there's a different level for
you to get obsessed crazy laser focus I
say all the time our obsessions become
our possessions but we won't possess
them if we're not truly obsessed that
there's been a person in your life
you've been obsessed with if you're over
20 years old listen to this
more than likely you've had somebody you
were pretty obsessed with haven't you
that you wanted in your life you wanted
to date you wanted as a girlfriend or a
boyfriend or significant other how many
times a day do you think about it how
many times a day did they distract you
from what you were doing with just the
thought of them in other words this is
what I want you understand when your
laser obsessed focused your obsession
distracts you from what you're currently
doing not the other way around you're
not really obsessed with it if you're
easily distracted from it this is so
important you right now can test whether
it's your obsession with whether it
distracts you constantly the first thing
you think of when you wake up last thing
before you go to bed
when you have a big laugh it comes up
when you cry it comes up when you're
watching TV it comes up when you're
doing your regular job but it's your
side hustle it comes up you can't stop
thinking about it it distracts you from
the rest of your life that's what an
obsession does when it's not really your
obsession the rest of your life
distracts you from it and so that it in
your life is so important but there's
all these things that distract us today
I'm gonna give you a recommendation turn
your damn TV off turn the radio off most
of the time turn your phone off a lot
too so here's the deal the TVs competing
constantly to distract you with stuff
that really doesn't matter
I'm not saying by the way don't be
informed don't know what's going on in
the world because that makes you more
interesting right you should know what's
going on in the world but let's be real
does it really matter what's going on
with the Kardashians right now is it
really matter they live on my street in
one of my neighborhoods right and
they're very nice people but I got to be
honest with you what happens in their
life doesn't dramatically impact my but
how many people are more obsessed with
the Kardashians and I can say this is
good friends we have many good friends
in reality television they're even
listening this right now and they would
tell you this don't be so obsessed with
them be obsessed with your own reality
TV program called your own life right
how about the news all the time to try
to distract us before it was Obama now
it's Trump you better trump's going
crazy today your mama's nuts about this
health care Iraq Iran North Korea right
like all these things and most of these
things don't impact our own lives I'm
not saying don't know about them but
it's such a convenient escape from the
work it's such a convenient escape from
our obsessions the left against the
right Republicans against Democrats
who's gonna be the next president who's
gonna get the Democratic nomination can
they beat Trump right who cares who
cares right now you got a win in your
own life and rule number five the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
developed mighty mission clarity with
Robin Sharma the majority are busy being
busy and they're addicted to devices and
addicted to alcohol and addicted to
busyness and addicted to gambling or
addicted to shopping or addicted to
worrying I mean in many ways it's become
a society of addicts and what's happened
is we develop addictions because we
escape from pain see potential
unexpressed
the potential you were born into if
you're not expressing it if you're not
living it if you're not releasing and
showing your primal glory every single
day then at a subconscious level you
you're developing you know anger and
sadness and guilt and shame over your
self betrayal against your genius and
rather than processing through that and
again at the Titan summit this year I'm
going to teach a tool called the afro
tool which my elite clients are finding
has revolutionized their lives if you
don't know these tools if you don't know
how to process through toxic emotions
that you know from life's hurts then you
repress it you develop what I call a
field of hurt and the field of hurt this
is so important the field of hurt is the
missing link to self mastery because
this field of hurt that develops as we
move through life and get discouraged
and knocked down or laughed at or we
betray our talents this field of hurt
then it's repressed toxic energy it
blocks us from our creativity and it
actually blocks us from epic
productivity and it blocks us from going
after opportunities and it blocks us
from leaving our gifts and our talents
and it blocks us from asking for what we
want and it blocks us from falling in
love with other people and with
ourselves and it blocks us for from the
prosperity that life wants for every
single one of us I mean life is meant to
be prosperous there is no lack in our
universe is there there's no lack of
apple blossoms and trees and flowers and
all those things the only reason we live
scarce lives if we do is because we are
blocked we are our own worst enemy so
what I want you to do point number two
is develop mighty mission clarity right
get really clear on what you want to
stand for in the world and what your
mighty mission is in the world and that
takes thinking in a world where we're so
busy we don't think anymore we don't
contemplate we don't introspect the
greatest genius has all spent a lot of
time in solitude they all spend a lot of
time alone they all take these retreats
and that's why they go live in Marisha
so they go live in Rome or they go live
here in London they get away and they
create and they think and they
in solitude and so please remember
there's no point in being very busy and
executing flawlessly around things that
don't matter
you do want to be a minimalist or a
purist around your few highest
priorities now I have a special bonus
clip with Robert Greene on how to shut
out the distractions that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one what is your mighty mission clarity
number two how can you block your time
for success and number three what will
you do tomorrow to start your day right
and if you made it this far in a video
and you are committed to making the
change I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believe down in the comments as
well there's differences and then
there's there's not differences so you
know the brain is the same the brain
evolved over the course of millions of
years so I try to make the point that
you know what da Vinci was going through
the process is that there's a template
there and it's the same because our
brains haven't really changed in an
evolutionary sense in four or five
hundred years on the other hand the
circumstances are different and people
now live in a world where there's many
more distractions so it's harder to do
that kind of focus that I was mentioning
so in some ways it's a little bit harder
and the people that I've interviewed are
really good at shutting out all of the
distractions of the world that's sort of
what separates them every single one of
them Paul Graham you know Paul Graham
Paul doesn't have a smartphone you know
he doesn't spend time on the Internet
he's extremely focused the woman yoky
Matsuoka
she she does all of her writing with a
pen and paper she's not sitting there
day in and day out on the computer
checking her Facebook or Twitter page or
whatever I could go through all of them
that way Steve Jobs is sort of the the
ultimate icon of mastery of our era and
he said the only thing that's
differentiated me
from everyone else was my level of focus
I could take a problem and I could focus
on it and burrow into it and everybody
else was so distracted he knew how to
close his door get away from his wife
his kids everyone and just focus so the
all of these people have to overcome the
tense distractions in our world they and
they're able to do it on the other hand
what you can get with a click on the
internet with a Google search compared
to what da Vinci had to do or a
scientist in the 19th or 20th century is
absolutely astounding so what you have
at your fingertips the knowledge the
things that you can connect and learn
about the potential for learning skills
is out of this world so if you're able
to overcome the distracting elements
that are its I my government I compare
it to if you ever watch a basketball
game and you see the opposing team
shooting free throw and everyone behind
him the stands are all going like this
with those big you know trying to
distract him there's like hundreds of
people that's what the world is like now
you've got thousands of people waving
those things you've got so many
distractions if you're able to overcome
that and be a person that can focus you
have this like wealth of information and
knowledge and ability to acquire skills
that nobody a hundred years ago 20 years
ago could dream about
if you want to learn the five lessons
you must learn before it's too late
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I lack discipline how can I get
discipline of my life and no one wants
to hear this answer no one wants to hear
it
find your passion thank you like what am
I supposed to do with that advice